see a shadow it's all cloudy there i
never do understand his
prognostication exactly those
floodlights and confusing about
whether he sees his shadow or doesn't
see a shadow and what that actually
means and i'm surprised he doesn't bite
that guy's nose off yeah right well no
disrespect whatsoever to the road and
back east but
you know we don't have groundhogs here
we've got our own spring prognosticator
it's mojave max the desert tortoise who
lives at the springs preserve
so max and all of his tortoise friends
will they bunk down for the winter don't
get up until spring-like weather is here
to stay
and for more than 20 years there's been
a contest for school kids to make their
best educated guess
as to the exact date and time that max
shows his reptile
face we're here to teach you about
desert tortoises and how to respect
protect and enjoy our desert so that's
from the
virtual program the folks from clark
county and get outdoors nevada have put
together for 14
area elementary schools we talk about
the desert we all share
how entering the mojave max emergence
contest is as easy
as a visit to mojavemax.com
and there are the t-shirts that the kids
in the winning students classroom get
they all get mojave max t-shirts
i don't know if they'll have max come
out to the springs preserve and
munch on some leafs but sherry you and i
have been talking about mojave max for
as long as i can remember
as long as i can remember and it's a
great education program for about our
conservation of the desert and the
animals who live there and
you know clark county's just done a
fantastic job and i think the adults
learn a lot too because the kids take it
home
alex and john and they they talk to
their parents about it so i think we all
learned something from it
yeah that's great absolutely i didn't oh
go ahead johnny i like that when we have
mojave max come out from his
for his broomation uh-huh uh that we
don't need top hats we don't need
tuxedos
at all you know it's it's simple it's
max is chill
absolutely when i wake up